hello everyone thank you so much for
joining us this afternoon I hope you
guys didn't have to wait too long in the
hot Sun although secretly I was hoping
that there'd be a a long line for our
talk my name is Ray I'm a product
manager on the Android media team and
I'm responsible for our Android Pro
Audio Android Pro Audio is an initiative
that we launched last year to bring
together device makers silicon partners
and Android engineers to provide a true
professional performance audio platform
for Android app developers this means
being able to write apps that use MIDI
high resolution input and output USB
digital audio floating point audio
processing and all of that with a
round-trip latency of less than 20
milliseconds now when we announced this
initiative we knew it was going to be a
multi-year effort with a lot of moving
parts some out of our control but even
though it's been only a year we've
actually seen some really exciting
developments from our hardware and
software partners and so with that I'd
like to introduce you to Dan to show
some really cool audio apps all right
thank you very much I'm Dan Galpin I'm a
developer advocate and I work with a lot
of partners to help build great audio
experiences on Android and I wanted to
first do a call out to my colleague Don
Turner he couldn't be here today so this
is Don turntable Turner as a young guy
working on his pro audio stuff and then
of course this is what his desk actually
looks like today it's a little neater
but there is a lot of passion in this
team about pro audio and I just want to
make it clear every single one of us up
here is the musician every single one of
us have here cares passionately about
what we do all right it's not it's not
that mind-blowing but it's still pretty
darn cool so let let me let me get
started with the first demo this is on a
nexus 9 and we're running DRC and you
know a lot of people have seen apps like
this ok we can have the the audio a foot
tell me that's working all right
okay that's pretty cool against a nice
nice low base here what's really neat
about this is in addition to this low
base I've also got this keyboard plugged
in here and what I can do is I can do
these high patches at the same time and
this is taking advantage of a future we
added an Android M to do actual to do
proper midian what's really cool about
this is in addition to actually be able
to do MIDI output like this is doing it
you'll also see MIDI input and this
device can actually reconfigure itself
to ask act act as a MIDI audio interface
you can plug this into a PC and it
actually looks just like a MIDI device
and this is cool because DRC actually
can work as a midi synthesizer for your
desktop workstation which is awesome and
we actually have an example of this over
in the pro audio sandbox for all of you
guys that are here alright so the next
time I'm going to pull this out the next
demo I'm going to show off is something
very very cool and this is the one I
really wish Don could have been here for
because Don is like an amazing amazing
DJ I on the other four on the other hand
and like super rank amateur but we're
going to show the G jiaying app and
we're going to be show this really
awesome device which is powered itself
off let me switch this off again hold on
give me like a moment here this is
what's just what's great you know you're
getting live demos when when I'm like
come on come on
work work work yes all right so now I've
got to do this all from scratch this was
all set up for you guys beforehand so
there'd be none of this corner stuff
going on but that's what's great about
doing this stuff live so we can deal the
audio from that and this is really cool
it's showing off really really cool low
latency Bluetooth along with low latency
audio and so I can go in Nick's between
these two tracks and that's what DJ's do
they create rhythmic patterns by going
between two different tracks like this
and you see how responsive this app is
of course I can also do this stuff like
scratch against the record as well
so that is example of doing really cool
Pro audio work deejay style here on
Android I'm going to unplug this on to
show one more app in this device though
so we can keep this going and this app
really needs no introduction all they
have to say is thanks to our partners
here at cord for doing K oscillator here
on Android really really awesome again
super thank you to them for the support
of Android pro audio ok I've got one
last demo one last demo to show you guys
here and last but certainly certainly
not least ah here we are
okay should be all plugged in and
connected alright so this is the noise
synthesizer from Roly and this is cool
you're seeing a virtual seaboard rise
which is an amazing instrument if you're
here at i/o you can actually check one
out in our pro audio sandbox and get to
play on it yourself with this amazing
multi-touch panel what's really cool is
it it's not just a keyboard but I can
actually move up and down to get
different effects I can also slide
across here do pitch bending and of
course you know fully multi-touch fully
multi-channel and it's really really
powerful what you can do with this you
can create almost any instrument with
incredible amounts of expression and
this is all running on the juice
platform which has been updated so that
anyone can build amazing pro audio apps
with really really low latency audio so
a big a big shout out to our partners
and friends over at Rowley for putting
this together for us and again there's
there's some amazing amazing people you
go onto YouTube just watch what people
do the Seaboard watch people do with
noise it's absolutely absolutely
incredible so that's the kind of stuff
we're doing really low latency audio
really professional applications alright
we can go back to the slides now alright
so yeah so I know I've seen this in
rehearsal but that was super impressive
every time I see it thank you so much
and again thank you to your partners
Rollie Rollie DJing DRC by imagine Ando
thank you so much so thanks ray I hope
you agree these are these are these are
some awesome experiences now developing
like apps like this isn't easy and our
partners have run into many problems
along the way so I'd like to share with
you some of the most common problems
they encounter in the solutions so you
don't have to go through the same level
of pain when you're developing your
audio apps now to put this more
interesting
you saw a preview of this I'm gonna put
some code on screen and I want you to
see if you can figure out what the
problem is with this code okay does
anyone at Cana want hands what's the
problem with this code anyone okay yes
it has a fixed sample rate yes okay
that's that is excellent thank you thank
you you can tell us you can tell we've
got people doing Perotti on here it's
fixed and that's a problem
because every Android device is a
preferred rate that is set by the system
and it's usually not forty four point
one kilohertz so so not only is this a
fixed sample rate but it's usually going
to be the wrong one and if that if that
happens your audio is going to be on a
resampler and so it's not going to be
able to go through the fast path which
means you're not going to get the lowest
latency so how do we solve this we can
use the Audio Manager API and query for
the device audio property and pass that
over to opensl yes I know what you're
saying and you're like wait I'm having
to use jan i like what look this is a
very small amount of j'ni it's very very
little effort and honestly this is an
enormous performance gain it's really
pretty simple so once again there's hi
this is how you've got the native sample
rate for the device okay another problem
is I'm getting high audio latency on
every single device why would this
happen all right so tell me what's
what's wrong with this code it's one
this one's actually pretty
straightforward anyone anyone why do I
always see the same hands okay back
there no there is there is okay shout
out it's got too big of a buffer it's
got too much buffers yes we should we
should have like parting gifts for this
this is awesome okay so yes that's
exactly the problem not only that it's a
fixed size so it's way too long
for low latency output at 4,000 frames
were talking 83 milliseconds now back in
the old days of Android back when I
first started ages ago that actually
wasn't that big of a buffer but today
our devices are way faster than that so
we're talking about 83 milliseconds of
just in this buffer so you're not going
to get super low latency audio that way
so what's the solution of course what we
want to do is go back and ask Audio
Manager say what is the best buffer size
we should be using what's the optimal
one and the device will tell us and then
if you use that buffer size and you're
opensl es callbacks like this you're
going to get the fast mixer you're going
to get the best audio playback in your
apps
okay well this doesn't solve all of your
problems because what happens if you're
actually are doing this cool synthesizer
that you wrote and you're and you're
hearing glitches but you know it's like
like wait I tap the screen and my
glitches go away okay so what you're
seeing here is Android trying to do
stuff about battery life okay and what
happens is if you're not touching the
screen Android goes well you're not
doing anything important no one's no
one's interacting with me and so it
scales back the CPU and this results in
late callbacks because you aren't able
to do as many work cycles this is
actually something we call the
interactive scheduler at work actually
trying to help you save battery
except you really don't want that
because you really want cool audio
playback so there is actually a way to
sort of work around this and it's it's
kind of a hack trick horrible thing that
will have a better solution for very
soon um but creative workaround I like
that yeah so this is what happens so the
system decides to throttle the CPU based
upon how often the user is touching the
screen so what we can do is we send fake
touches and convinces of the screen is
still being touched I know here the
ground something on hey look look don't
shoot the messenger okay I mean but note
this this this and out now Android will
go okay the screen is constantly being
touched thinks that it's in an
interactive mode and this is really
important if you're doing something like
input or if you're using even if you're
doing like a VR app and you're using
sensors like you're not touching the
screen Android might say whoa I
shouldn't be doing anything now but so
this does actually actually work it
convinces Android the screen is being
touched and seriously like yeah
we're going to do something better okay
last problem is one I hear the most you
know it's we spend a lot of time
debugging we get audio glitches and
crackles they've done all the other
things right annual for example we've
got an app that's running at a device
with a you know 192 frame size buffer
and it's sample rate of 48 kilohertz
which means you're going to get
callbacks every 4 milliseconds and in
those 4 milliseconds you have to
generate 192 frames of audio data and if
you don't you're going to get a glitch
but the problem is is that is it is it
is that in fact the cause of it is that
you're not always able to supply it in
time and the reason the real question is
why why was your app not always able to
actually supply this data in time and
there are two possible causes you know
one of them is you might be blocking or
you might be doing too much work in the
callback and let's take a quick look at
some causes of those so first thing you
want to do is check for any blocks in
the audio callback this means going
through your code and just analyzing it
you know examining it and checking for
things like waiting on other threads
j'ni calls which basically is kind of
like waiting on other threads because it
adds synchronization which could block
you memory allocations believe it or not
memory allocations actually can block
you not shocking system calls also can
block and of course you can use systrace
with audio scared and freaking out how
do you feel here use systrace raise
hands that is not nearly enough more
people should use systrace it is an
awesome awesome tool if you want to
learn more about using systrace you can
come to my session or come on line for
tomorrow at 9:00 9:00 a.m. over an Ursa
Minor okay and I'll be talking about
systrace once you eliminate any blocks
you need to figure out how much work
you're doing and you can do this using
clock get time as this gives you
nanosecond accuracy and logging inside
the callback is problematic so you want
to keep that to a minimum and a trick
you can use is to keep a calendar the
callbacks only log on every X number of
calls and there's even better tricks
like keeping a ring buffer or you can
use the trace command with this trace
which is pretty cool to create trace
segments there's a native API we added
an M for that so it doesn't even force a
J and I call which is great and then the
other thing that can drastically affect
your performance is your build
configuration always make sure that you
do not debug your debug build I know
this doesn't make sense what we're doing
performance debugging you always want to
make sure
are actually looking at your release
build because it's going to be a lot
faster we take out a lot of things also
make sure to check your compiler flags
you know hardware float and neon can
make a massive massive difference please
check out our high performance audio
website where we publish the flags that
we actually use as a team so make sure
the compiler is actually generating what
you think it is use like waa s LH dump
annotated assembly if you're not sure
and this is really great if you've ever
wanted to learn what compilers do and
just how great they can be and sometimes
I so how now how not great take a look
at the assembly that's generated it's
very very eye-opening ok this is kind of
the hardest and most painful one for me
don't use more than 20% of your callback
budget to generate data and so what this
means is that if you're seeing you're
taking more than about a quarter of that
time what you should do is try to scale
back things scale back effects scale
back the amount of polyphony because the
chances are you're going to get a glitch
and or even worse get a whole bunch of
glitches or maybe the device will even
heat up so giving yours by trying to
take only about 20 to 25% of that time
you really really radically reduce the
chances of glitching and ultimately we
want to make this better and we're
working to increase this both with bug
fixes and n which Glenn will talk about
and by working closely with our silicon
partners but for now especially in older
devices and we're talking about current
Android sticking to this rule will give
you the best stability on a wide range
of devices so that's about all the more
stories I have time for today but you
can read more about all of this and keep
up with any new developments on the
Android pro audio webpage alright
so as you can see it really is possible
to write a great professional audio app
on Android damn thank you for all the
tips the pitfalls to avoid and the best
practices thank you for that all right
and of course it should not be that
difficult to make a great Android audio
app so we're not going to be happy until
we have an easy-to-use API and an audio
platform that can guarantee consistent
predictable performance and that's also
something that's not just available in a
few devices but on a myriad of devices
so we're little ways off from finishing
our Android pro audio story but we've
done some really important work this
year and to give you a progress report I
want to introduce you to Glenn latency
crusher casting
I like that name latency pressure it's
much better than my other nickname which
is glitch Caston it was really painful
for me to see Dan talking about glitches
because I spend a lot of my time
thinking about glitches and listening to
them anyway so for me I really believe
that creativity should be for everyone
that everyone should feel empowered to
be creative and we all deserve it
it shouldn't just be for a select few
and I believe that there's billions of
people out there including Android users
who should be able to be creative in my
family we're musicians four of us play
piano including me and I'd like to
introduce to you my son wrap master
Raiden Aiden he likes to create music -
he plays acoustic piano and also
electronic keyboards and microphone
unfortunately he doesn't play music on
Android not yet this gives me such a
pain even more than hearing glitches and
the reason is because Android just
hasn't had the consistent level of high
performance that creative audio
applications need and Aidan's not
satisfied and other musicians haven't
been ready yet or haven't been satisfied
yet either creative audio applications
require a lot of CPU they require
consistently they need to run every few
milliseconds this is pro level of
performance and that's why we call it
pro audio the pro is for the pro level
of performance not for who happens to be
using it we believe that pro audio again
is for everyone
that's where Android comes in that's our
strength one of our strengths is being
able to be accessible to many many
people the openness the wide range of
form factors and price points my work
mission is to reduce audio latency to
improve performance to reduce glitches
things like that we introduced the pro
audio program overall a year ago but
actually I've been working with my
colleagues for over three years now
initially on latency in 2013 at i/o we
announced some major reductions in
output latency along with my colleagues
and then the next year we announced
reductions in input latency the
following years we talked about USB
audio which enables really high quality
audio interfaces and we also introduced
MIDI which is what makes music tick
that's my slogan one thing we found
though was that features were not enough
that we had to have this consistent
level of performance and both our app
developers and our users needed a way
that they could tell really easily
whether a device was going to be capable
of that level of performance and have
all the features they needed so we
introduced last year this thing that we
call the pro audio feature flag it
brings together all the key things that
you need for pro level of performance
low latency midi USB the 24-bit data
path and I'm probably missing something
else but it has basically all the core
elements it gives us something to shoot
for us personally in the android
framework team and it also gives our OEM
partners and our silicon partners
something that they can shoot for I
mentioned that one of Android strengths
is the diversity of our ecosystem we
have a large number of different form
factors different price points and
things like that and for Android it's
not realistic at this point to expect
that we can get Android pro audio
performance everywhere and we
acknowledge that with the pro audio flag
so now we have something to shoot for
something to differentiate and certainly
yes I would like to have more and more
devices support that but initially it's
our first step and at the beginning we
only had a few devices in the Nexus
family that claimed the priority of flag
but things are changing I see hope now
for additional devices from other OEMs
from other silicon makers that are also
going to be supporting the priority of
light so please stay tuned for that
so I mentioned earlier that one of my my
main day job is is getting rid of
glitches and decreasing latency it turns
out that we can't do that all just in
the framework certainly part of it is in
the portable framework but a lot of it
has to do with the device dependent goat
so I work really closely with partners
these include partners within the fellow
Googlers in in the android framework and
kernel teams and performance teams but
also external partners device OEMs
silicon makers people like such as that
there's one partner that I've been
working with in particular that I want
to mention now he's a fellow Googler he
works in the Chrome OS team and he's
really helped us to investigate and
challenge some of the assumptions that
we've been making about latency let me
give an example of one assumption that I
used to make that was totally incorrect
people would say Oh your round trip
latency is whatever you know 20
milliseconds whatever what's the output
latency and I would say well I don't
know but let's let's call it a half or
maybe it's a little more than half well
that's not good enough
and I'd like to introduce mark he's a
physicist by training and he cares about
numbers and getting them right and even
better than that he works with lasers
thanks hi my name is Mark I work on the
chrome OS touch team and we care a lot
about latency and I'm guessing a lot of
you do too now it's not only latency
there are a bunch of different ways an
application can interact with the
physical world and all the interaction
channels listed here have a typical
latency of milliseconds or tens of
milliseconds now timing physical events
with millisecond accuracy is no rocket
science but when you're trying to time
them relative to events that happen
inside the CPU it gets pretty messy look
something like this and then when you
try to touch the device and lick use the
touchscreen with all those probes
sticking out of the guts of the phone it
gets very frustrating I tried it that's
one of the reasons that the numbers we
usually see our round-trip latencies
I'll be using in a drum pad application
as an example here the
pipeline of the vent Lutz looks
something like this
so the round-trip and latency in this
case is the time from the moment
somebody touches the screen and until
sound scum comes out but the subsystems
involved in such a round-trip represent
a bunch of different engineering teams
often spread across different companies
and if there is a bug who is should be
looking for it the blame wars are no fun
and as a physicist I love I have a
little obsession with good measurement
instruments and for the last several
months I have was likely to work on
building one that does exactly the kind
of measurements that we are looking for
the basic idea is that we use device
that synchronizes clocks with the phone
and then we can separately measure the
time that passes from the moment we
touch the screen and until the app got
got the event and in the other direction
from the moment that up initiated some
output and some visible or audible
change has been produced we called it
the world latency timer now this is a
very early prototype in audio setup but
it's fairly simple this is a more recent
device that can measure latency on most
of the channels that I've mentioned
earlier the good news is that it can
work without the need to modify the
device or even route it and we have
recently open-source to put this project
is now all on github and Walt has
produced some interesting results for
Android audio and for touch as well back
to Glenn
thank you Mark one thing here that
shocked me was seeing that the audio
output latency here was 13 and the input
was 5 you know I'd been telling people
incorrectly oh just guess half and half
well I was totally wrong when you think
about it it makes more sense it has to
do with the number of buffers and and
where they are in the pipeline and
things like that but it just shows you
how important is to actually measure
things and not just guess so together
working in the android framework team
together with our partners in the kernel
team performance team our silicon
partners our Orion partners we've made a
lot of progress in in reducing latency
and improving performance I want to now
turn the subject to what we're doing
what we've just been working on just the
last few months so you have a sort of a
feeling of what we're up to right now
and I'm talking about what's going on in
the in release
first of all I've made a lot of mistakes
in my career I'm happy to admit that one
of them was I was so aggressive at
trying to reduce latency that I took
some some shortcuts and cut some corners
that have in retrospect turned out to be
not advisable one of those was on the
output side in the in the device driver
we've always had double buffering and
there are some very good reasons for
that but on the on the app level we were
encouraging app developers to do single
buffering in in the application with the
rationale being that the app could
provide the data immediately and
everything would be ok oh that works
fine for apps that create sine waves but
fortunately or unfortunately those are
not not real pro audio apps real pro
audio apps apps such as the ones that
you saw dan demo earlier use a huge
amount of CPU and they would like to use
way more than 20% and to do that into it
reliably without glitching even under
stressful conditions you need to have
double buffering in the application
level so I'm happy to announce that in
the end we're finally enabling double or
even further
buffering in the application level for
those apps that need it and with an
accompanying very slight increase in
latency of course but it's usually not
important then the other thing I want to
mention is for those of you who love the
SDK the SDK is still there and we've
improved the audio latency on the audio
track API s2 so that you can take
advantage of some of the improvements
we've been making in latency there too
you've heard at both the keynote in lots
of sessions this week about our VR
effort and VR is very focused on
performance especially predictable
performance it turns out that VR is by
nature a real-time kind of application
very similar to pro audio and their
needs are very similar to ours so we've
been working very closely with VR and
the performance teams right now the
features that you've heard about with VR
such as sustained performance mode those
are only available for VR as of now
however we are working together and I
really hope to be able to bring those
kind of performance guarantees to other
vertical domains such as pro audio and
any other use cases like that as long as
we're talking about VR I wanted to
mention there's a VR session tomorrow
morning at 9:00 a.m. I hope you can
attend one of my colleagues is printing
presenting on VR audio and also we also
have another presentation by Dan
tomorrow morning also competing with
that on the indie Kay so both should be
of interest to you and hopefully you can
split yourself to go to both sessions
okay so here again is the website for
all things audio for all things / audio
it's bitly hi - performance - audio if
you don't remember any other URL please
remember that one so although we have
been making progress on the light over
the last three years I do want to
acknowledge that we're not done yet
and we certainly have a lot more work
left ahead of us and some of which I
know about some of which I can't predict
yet because we haven't hit them yet what
I will share with you is what we're
working on right now that we know about
and I'm acknowledging that yes these are
problems and the good thing though is
despite these problems it is
possible to get real work done on
Android as you've seen these four apps
earlier the first thing is more
predictable CPU scheduling and CPU
bandwidth so you don't need tricks like
the fake touch and also so that you can
use more than 20% of the CPU the next is
our API we recognize that open SLES is
our hard to use API requires a lot of
boilerplate code and just saying opensl
es is awkward
I want a simpler name so we're listening
to developers and I can't make any
promises yet about what it will be what
it will look like but we are working on
a new API and don't worry if you love
opensl es it will still be there
finally round-trip latency currently our
goal for the Pro Audio flag is 20
milliseconds and that is good for many
many applications especially
applications that only do output only
processing because then they don't the
their latency is a only a portion of
this however there are applications such
as guitar processing voice processing
that can benefit from even lower latency
so we are working towards that magic 10
millisecond round-trip latency figure
and I want to achieve that without
causing power problems it turns out in
the lab we have hit 10 millisecond
round-trip but it used too much power
and so it's not really ready for release
yet so I won't be done with this effort
until Adan is happy being creative on
Android and until all of you are happy
being creative on Android thank you for
coming today
at this point I want to switch through
some acknowledgments you already heard
some acknowledgments from from Dan about
our app partners a few of whom are in
the room today so look for them later on
for me personally though the the people
that I work with most closely are
silicon and device OEMs and I want to
acknowledge a few of them by name
although I've worked with many of them
first of all Qualcomm has really worked
hard to reduce the audio latency and
their signal path especially in the DSP
they've been optimizing that recently
another company I'd like to acknowledge
is Nvidia they've been focusing on
improving performance and reliability
instability of scheduling and tasks wake
up I'm really thrilled to announce that
the demos that we saw today at least one
of the demos was done on the Nvidia
shield k1 and using an early build of
Android that supports Android / audio
flag and for more information please
check out these URLs and video we'll be
happy to if you sign up for there to let
you download / OTA
a special developer preview of their
android priority or access and if you
have questions about that later on
we have people in the audience we have
projector thank you for Jetta and Bill
who can also answer your questions about
Android pro do on in video there's one
company though that I want to
acknowledge that I work with even more
than that I want to give them very
special thank you and that's Samsung
mobile the reason is is that we're kind
of late to the pro audio party we
started thinking about it a few years
ago but it turns out Samsung Mobile has
been has had that on the radar for many
many years they saw a real gap in
Android compared to our competitor
platforms and they started working on it
and over the last few years they've been
working on the Samsung Pro Audio SDK
evolving it coming out with multiple
releases and along with accompanying
apps that work well on the pro audio SDK
so I want to acknowledge Samsung Mobile
and invite both Taemin Cho and Johnny
SEO up to the stage thank you
do you have a mic yep again thank you
hello my name is Johnny so I'm product
owner of something professional audio in
sound camp
I really appreciate a clan and Ray
inviting us on this stage edges so in
this session Android Pro Audio has great
potential and opportunities for Android
developers and I believe it will be
great even great with a sometime
professional audio and it's
collaboration with Android provide you
our lead engineer team and Joe will give
you more details about it hi
samsung professional audio also called
saba for short is Samsung's own
professional audio framework it was
first released in 2013 and it has a two
major features of course the first one
is a low latency audio the first version
shows the 16 millisecond long trip
latency on Galaxy Note 3 and the second
one is the interpretation of the routing
which allows the streaming audio and
MIDI between different applications yes
less more details about the
interpretation of the routing so here is
an audio application you made and you
want to add some effects to the sound
then you have to build a brief X into
the same application or using Saba you
can connect your app to other effects
apps you can connect as many apps you
want depending on the CPU in whatever
form in serial and parallel without no
ed with no additional delay suppose in
the application audio routing is based
on the well-known check audio connection
case so if you're familiar with the chat
already then you
shape gotcha so with this even you can
build a PC like a da WM so you can load
multiple plug-in instruments and impacts
run them simultaneously and mix the
sound is highly extensible and Samsung
also provide the own DWF which has a
plug-in architecture so you just make a
plug-in and use that sapa in order to
achieve the low latency sup ha actually
we made supper independent from the
audio Android audio system so this why
sapa is only available on samsung
devices but within this year sapa is
running on the Android audio system
because thanks to the Android pro do the
low latency is available on Android
audio system 10 means sapa is also
available on non Samsung devices so
simply thank you so Samsung decide is
for the next flagship device our next
flagship device we going to support the
Android pro do Hardware flag thank you
and if you need more information please
you know refer to the URL here and sense
the Christians to saba s samsung.com and
if you have any urgent question ask me
or Johnny thank you so much for coming
today we look forward to seeing you at
the demo booth - thank you